il s'appelle un position avantageuse
avantage fiscal réfaction ou encore
dispositif d'abattement fiscal une
ristourne obtenus dans les outre mer
pour contourner la vie chère une mesure
accordée dans les années 60
sa remise en cause suscite l'hostilité
[Musique]
finalement l'abattement outre-mer par
est insignifiant pour les 64 mille
foyers fiscaux qui disent paient
beaucoup trop d'impôts de 116 millions
d'euros générés en 2010 est en
martinique et qui servent à l'état
l'abattement est de 30% aux antilles 40
% en guyane et à mayotte un abattement
qui sera bientôt redéfinit pour les
contribuables qui déclarent plus de
100000 euros par an seuls 70 millions
d'euros sur les 400 millions d'euros que
représente cet avantage seront
réallouées et ce seront effectivement
les contribuables ultra marins les plus
riches
en clair ceux qui payent le plus d'un
pouce le revenu les 5% de ceux qui paie
le plus d'impôts sur le revenu qui
seront concernés par cette mesure parce
que on doit le dire les inégalités
outre-mer et notamment en martinique est
aussi en guadeloupe sont plus
importantes entre les plus riches et les
plus pauvres qu'ailleurs et donc il
s'agit un petit peu de l'établir de la
justice sociale de la solidarité 70
millions d'euros généré un chiffre mis
en doute par les parlementaires
martiniquais ils craignent un
élargissement aux classes moyennes et un
désengagement de l'état
le riche pas tout à fait juste parce que
ça représente que autour de 7% le
montant recherché toute le famille en
europe à en croire financiers seront là
que le fonds d'investissement
exceptionnel en fait que les
martiniquais vont financer eux mêmes ce
besoin faibles symptômes soient pas
atteints puisque les 5%
c'est soit phone 7 à sa fin huit
millions temps qui manque 30 millions
donc les couches moyennes sont aussi
impactés par ce prélèvement moi tout ça
est très injuste
quarante ans après la mise en place de
l'abattement fiscal l'écart de prix avec
la france hexagonale est compris entre
30 et 40%
un argument que défendront les
parlementaires outre-mer lors du vote en
septembre prochain